I don't trust in the public educational  system I don't if a person can make  money if the person can make money  enough money like you know how people  just sell the dream on hey go make money  so you can buy Ferrari or Lambo or Bill  if you can go make money to get your  kids out of public school to put them in  a private school that's teaching the  values and principles that align with  you go make your money for that that'll  be better worth of your money being  spent than going and buying a fancy car  or dream house yeah I'm not I'm not a  fan of what's going on public schools  yeah so some want to do homeschooling  and some can take the alternative and  put them in a good private school